it could be interesting to only allow
friends to challenge me but then that
would incentivize everyone to become my
friend okay let's click always and I'll
wait oh maybe I'll give yo Han your
honza first to challenge of course more
wait the minute hon I'm gonna pause a
minute on oh this is rated Blitz okay
I'm gonna try and continue remembering
how the pieces move what's the play here
play play b6 I'm gonna play kind of a
slow kind of double fiend kettle so I
think there's a lot of like aliping
players they like they like open
positions not to stereotype but I'm
gonna try and play against the the
typical style of a an elephant player is
a free pawn my opponent stocking a pawn
or blundering upon to open the position
oh yeah Bishop f3 it's play this move I
think it's better to develop efficiently
rather than continually moving my bishop
d5 okay so my bishop probably wants to
develop to the square d6 would have lost
a piece because Queen a4 have to be
careful not to blunder also let me know
if thing was looking sound okay I forgot
to ask that once people arrived it's a
slightly new setup life I've got five so
I haven't moved either Center pawn this
is somewhat unusual oh you look great
okay that's all I need to hear I can
move
take the night can move the night back
hey pizza racer also do do people hear
the voice because I didn't check the the
volume I can hear the voice not sure
whether to take this kind of interesting
moment could take you all move back yeah
let's move back because it's actually in
the way of the bishop and this lights in
the way of other nights in 96 I think
that night wants to come to c7 so it
prepares b5 and pressures d5
yeah I'm looking at chats but I don't
always look at chats because fighting
the game I'll make an effort to look at
chat oh you hear no voice I have to
figure out the audio let me experiment
for a moment properties maybe defaults
okay I think there should be audiio now
play this move yeah people should be
able to hear the pieces moving at least
okay so my Knights are actually I
coordinated if I okay 95 is tricky
because if I played d6 I lose a pawn but
then maybe I trap at night mmm probably
too risky those are just gonna prepare
b5 I'm b5 I'm scared of d6 I think I'll
play I'll play this idea
bring my Knight to d6 yeah welcome back
bicycles oh yeah Korea yeah Korea is
like without their side of the world at
least for some people
I told bicycle that we can play a game
if bicycles challenging me that will be
the next game the time stamps were
clutch for the most recent video
actually yeah I took a lot of work to
condense the time stamps because YouTube
has a 5,000 character limits I think
initially it was over 10,000 okay let's
focus let's play play work beads
oh it's la Diana welcome back Neil I
didn't see you
oh yeah we played a game that I keep
forgetting to put on YouTube
this move play this move
oh wait I just plundered da
Neil you distracted me but does my
opponent see it because there's so much
action in the center this might be
misdirection also apply whole gifting 5
subs thanks so much bye hole more
distractions just what I need I'm down
material do we have we have Jam JM t0u
the people's pots are lucky Lucy 6 1 9
leave this move I should stay focused
because this is rated I have a thought
to try and win this game without moving
my center pawns it might be difficult
though I still want to play this move no
Brooke b7 f3 is coming i 3 takes and
then loses pawn so maybe this move ideas
just to over defend a mine I will return
wait Sharky croc did you play Tata Steel
oh I know there is I mean there is other
sections of Tata Steel apart from the
mastery section it would be a cool
tournament to play I'm playing in the
same general locations it's all players
ok what to do
so I'm down the exchange but ooh do I
have tactics let's move I don't think it
works
let's take c-4 there's not enough to
unfortunately there's also Queen off -
hmm I can fiend kettle my knight that
would be really sad queenie 727 takes c4
nothing seems to work
take Stig's okay I have a thought we
look like when a7 it takes I think I can
just take back if takes 5 97 and then g6
ideas oh you got a plus score plus score
is better than firoozeh right
I think firoozeh finished I mean he was
leading at some points but then he
finished at 50% he played some good
players ok what to do g5 my first g5 of
the stream maybe I don't think it's a
bad move it's kind of overextending
there's also this crazy move sort of
takes and takes the problem is maybe
this move and I lose a a sacred centre
pawn let's do it
it looks enjoyable there's a some idea
if the knight moves somewhere I played
Bishop T fourth check not sure if that
does much but dark squares could be weak
and you edit your videos yes there's not
too much editing that like comes into
play and but I mean most videos I I
download I cut the start point and end
point I export I upload I do the
descriptions tagging I do all my
thumbnails let's take a wait no Bishop
d4 maybe I forgot g6 is let's attack
twice let's start with Bishop there's
I'm d4 so I'm gonna have to try and
prove that the dog is being excited the
dog sees something that I don't see I
have to prove that my my minor pieces
are better than rooks which might be
might be a reasonable argument to make
because of this I have amazingly queen
bee eights the king has nowhere safe to
go upon his poison the dog is trying to
warn my opponent Wow am I just getting
smashed oh this is not good I have to
take this is really not good though
Queen b6 maybe I'm not dead yet
live this move and if it takes I have
Queen f6 okay we're gonna trade
I still haven't moved a single Center
pawn also it was a smooth like that for
Bishop III we got one nothing works
I'm also low on time Bishop f6 so now I
have to prove that my Oh free night
every night feels like Christmas
Christmas was like a month ago so
generous I think my opponent got nervous
my phone it was just up a pawn had a
nice night Gotham chess what's up if
you're just joining I was getting
crushed and my opponent gave me a
unbelieving Christmas gift yeah let's
move back it's very possible I'll win
this game without moving either Center
pawn I did this move I want to break
through it's actually start with taking
and then I'll put the work on unbeatens
and rook b2 coming
even better this targeting g3 put the
bishop here look g1 and then I'll just
start winning pawns mmm and play this
move my opponent wants opposition maybe
ooh I could take a pawn I'm looking for
a meeting like it's so close to meet Oh
actually this might be okay
I didn't want to move my son your pawns
but if I'm meeting then I guess it's
worth it yeah uh I wanted to title the
YouTube video winning a chess game
without moving the center pawns now I
have to think of a different title
anyway maybe I'll put that on YouTube
that was a fun game that was a slightly
tragic game for my opponents given that
um yeah it was I mean I was just it felt
like I was getting crushed here
wondering if there was anything better
maybe Knight takes like avoid the Queen
trade and threaten this I could've been
very bad
anyway you two people thanks for
watching see you in the future I need to
start making more YouTube content